earlier at Comic Con a humongous
announcement was made an announcement
that when I first saw the headline I was
like that's funny and then I continued
to see more headlines and more headlines
and I was claimed it's true
it's true in the Year 2015 the Man of
Steel sequel will come out and it will
start none other than Batman himself
henry cavill will be reprising his role
as the Man of Steel and the Batman has
not yet been cast of course I mean if
they announced that they also cast
Batman in the movie it's just too much
for me to handle now the idea of a
Batman Superman movie has been going
around for a very long time I remember
before Batman Begins was announced as
the official new Batman movie back when
it was called Batman the intimidation
game yeah I was following all that news
back then as well they were thinking
about making a Batman vs Superman movie
it was in the cards for a while but it
didn't pan out now they're talking about
making a movie where they both team up
again it doesn't say anything about vs.
or that they'll be against each other
but my thoughts on this are that that
would be incredible now let me explain
how it would be incredible because there
is a way to really mess this up in my
opinion the best way hands-down that
these guys can approach this material is
the world's finest route and let me
explain what I'm talking about
besides the Nolan Batman films in my
opinion the best incarnation of Batman
there ever was was the animated series
from the 90s and that goes for the
Superman cartoon as well
and both of them actually did team-up in
the Batman Superman movie from the 90s
this was like a four-episode arc or
something and they did it perfectly I
mean most DC fans will tell you that
that is one of the best ways they could
have done it there there really is no
other better way that could have done it
through animation at that time the
characters were so well realized they
were exactly how they should be their
opposition at first was an absurd
over-the-top like hey let's just make
Batman and Superman hate each other for
no reason it was logical Superman was
like hey Batman why are you in my town
I don't want vigilante justice here and
Batman just takes Superman and throws
him across a bar into a
table and Batman just stands there
staring at Superman incredible
that was fan worthy poo my pants 1990s
child pooed my pants in the 90s moment
that they got a really look to that has
advice and of course the original comics
in which they did team up Zack Snyder
will be helming it I'm glad he's
returning Henry Cavill as I said will be
returning as well Christopher Nolan and
Emma Thomas will also be returning as
executive producers this time not
producers I'm glad that he's still
involved in some way shape or form but
the piece of information that is most
interesting to me is the casting who are
they're gonna cast as Batman who do I
think they should cast as Batman I gotta
be honest I have no idea I have no idea
here's an idea
cast an unknown actor and having be
voiced by Kevin Conroy
don't do that that's a bad idea I do
love Kevin Conners voice though man that
guy is just you know Kevin Conroy yes
I'm trying to figure out in my head if
they should cast a big actor or an
unknown actor I really don't know about
the Batman thing all I know is that they
better get someone who does it right but
who also has his own stamp on it and the
Batman suit my word I just can't wait to
see what the Batman suit is please don't
be horribly stupid I really want it to
be like this grungy Batman like the
Batman Arkham Asylum Batman you know
where he's just got long ears he's all
dirty and grungy but the same time
tactical and smart I'm hoping that this
movie is going to be just everything
that I want it to be I'm really hoping
that with this movie they can launch a
new Batman it can help the new Superman
film be even better and at the same time
perhaps put Justice League still on the
cards in a good way because I really
think they're doing this correctly I
don't think it would have been smart to
just have Batman show up in a Justice
League movie the idea of having a
world's finest movie first is an
excellent idea I just hope that you
don't screw it up because this is
literally like fanboy dream right here
and can I just say that this is coming
out in 2015 what is up with that year
bonds 24 Star Wars 7 Avengers to another
world's finest movie I don't even think
I'm going to be able to contain myself
so guys what do you think about this new
piece of news what are your thoughts on
it who do you think maybe you should
play Batman do you think it should be
unknown or someone famous
do you think they should take a lot of
advice from that animated
what are your guys thoughts on all of
this and by the way I just came back
from Indiana with my buddy John and I
made a pretty entertaining and
hilariously random Batman versus Bane
video where we shot Roman candles at
each other I put a link for that in the
description it's a lot of fun actually I
hope you guys check that out thanks as
always guys for watching and if you like
this you can click right here and get
stuck mine eyes